president joe biden's cabinet looks
quite different from that of his
predecessor donald trump naturally it
skews more diverse and liberal but as
far as personal wealth goes it's far
less the members have a combined total
net worth of 118 million dollars
compared to trump's cabinet combined
worth of 6.2 billion here's a quick look
at what each member is worth president
joe biden 8 million dollars vice
president kamala harris 7 million
dollars attorney general merrick garland
20 million dollars secretary of the
treasury janet yellen 20 million dollars
secretary of state anthony blinken 10
million dollars secretary of commerce
gina raimondo 10 million dollars
secretary of energy jennifer granholm 8
million dollars
secretary of homeland security alejandro
mallorca's 8 million
secretary of defense lloyd austin 7
million
secretary of health and human services
javier becerra seven million dollars
secretary of agriculture tom vilsack
four million dollars secretary of
veterans affairs dennis mcdonald three
million dollars secretary of labor marty
walsh 2.5 million dollars secretary of
housing and urban development marcia
fudge two million dollars secretary of
education miguel cardona one million
dollars
secretary of transportation pete
boudojes 750 000. and secretary of the
interior deb holland zero
forbes estimates holland's personal net
worth at zero based on a review of her
financial disclosure and public records
in a filing from december 2020 she had
just two items a student loan worth no
more than fifty thousand dollars and a
175 dollar annual tribal payment
you